does it hurt you that the FBI by certain
people is distrusted or even hated 100
it kills me I I like I've never until
recently not I sometimes be embarrassed
about
the FBI sometimes which is really really
hard for me to say because I love that
place I love the people in it I love the
the Brotherhood that you have with you
know all the guys in your squad you know
guys and girls I just use guys you know
you know we
I I developed a real drinking problem
there because we were so social of going
out after after work and and you know
continuing on it really was a family
um you know so I do miss that
um
but yeah I mean if someone could become
an FBI agent I mean it's pretty [ __ ]
cool man so the day you graduate and
walk out of the academy with a gun and a
badge and you know the the power to
charge someone with a misdemeanor for
flying to the United States flag at
night that's awesome
so there is a part of like representing
and loving your country and especially
if you're doing cyber security so
there's a lot of technical Savvy in
there in different places in the FBI
yeah I mean there there's different
pieces sometimes you know you'll see an
older agent that's done you know not
cyber crime come over to cyber crime at
the end so he can get a job once he goes
out uh but there's also some some guys
that come in
um you know I won't name his name but
there was a guy I mean I think he was a
hacker when he was a kid and now he's
been an agent now he's way up in
management
um great guy I love this guy and he
knows who he is if he's listening
um you know that that you know he had
some skills but we also lost a bunch of
guys that had some skills because uh we
had one guy in the squad um that he had
to leave the FBI because his wife became
a doctor and she got a residency down in
Houston and and she couldn't move uh he
he wasn't allowed to transfer so he
decided to keep his family versus the
FBI so there's some stringent rules in
the FBI that that need to be relaxed a
little bit yeah I love hackers turned
like leaders like one of my quickly
becoming good friends is much
he was a big hack in the 90s and then uh
now was recently
Twitter
Chief security officer CSO but he had a
bunch of different leadership positions
including being my
boss at Google but
um but originally a hacker it's cool to
see like hackers become like leaders I
just wonder what would cause him to stop
doing it why he would then take like a
like a managerial route very high-tech
companies I think a lot of those guys so
this is like the 90s they really were
about like the freedom
uh there's like a philosophy to it and
when I think the hacking culture evolved
over the years and I think when it
leaves you behind you start to realize
like oh actually what I want to do is I
want to help the world and I can do that
in legitimate routes and so on but
that's the story that yeah I would I
would love to uh talk to him one day but
I I wonder how common that is to like
young hackers turn turn good you're
saying it like pulls you in it's if
you're not careful it can really put you
in yeah you know you're good at it you
become powerful you become you know
everyone's slapping on the back and say
what a good job and all that you know at
a very young age yeah so yeah I would
love to get into my buddy's mind on why
he stopped hacking and moved on Ah
that's gonna be a good conversation in
in his case maybe it's always about a
great woman involved
family and so on yeah that grounds you
um
uh because like we have there is a
danger to hacking that that uh once
you're in a relationship once you have
family maybe you're not willing to
partake in